انضم إلينا الآن نيك روبرتسون
الذي أمضى الكثير من حياته المهنية في تغطية
المملكة العربية السعودية وكان
هناك مؤخرًا في المملكة وهو
يتحدث إلينا الآن من لندن ، ما
رأيك بهذه الخطوة من قبل
واشنطن وأعتقد أن هناك عددًا من  الأمور
هنا على المحك ، هناك
قضايا سعودية محددة وإعادة تقويم
تلك العلاقة ودعنا نواجه الأمر
أه محمد بن سلمان ، كان لولي العهد
علاقة حميمة جدًا
مع إدارة أه ترامب
التي كانت قادرة على الذهاب مباشرة
إلى صهر الرئيس
أه كبير مستشاريه السياسيين في الشرق الأوسط أه ،
لقد كان قادرًا على قطع
وزارة الخارجية في بعض الأحيان ، أدى ذلك إلى احتكاك
أحيانًا حتى مع وزير الخارجية في
عهد الرئيس ترامب ،
لذا فهذه إشارة واضحة جدًا
لن تكون  المستقبل
هو ازدراء علني للغاية بطريقة ما ،
لكنني لا أعتقد أن البيت الأبيض
ينخدع بالاعتقاد أنه إذا
التقط الرئيس بايدن الهاتف
وتحدث إلى الملك سلمان بدلاً من
ابنه ،  لن يعرف موقع on ما
يقال أو لن يكون له مدخلات
حول كيفية استجابة الملك وقد منح ولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان
هذه السلطة من
قبل والده لقيادة رؤية جديدة
لمستقبل البلاد ولكني أعتقد ذلك
يخبرنا أيضًا بشيء مهم جدًا
حول كيفية اعتزام الرئيس بايدن
تكوين حلفاء حول العالم